on Saturday William's parents gave birth
to twins and name them Nadia and Vanessa
when they were first born Nadia weighed
7.27 pounds and was 21.5 inches tall and
Vanessa weighed 8.34 pounds how much did
the babies weigh in total so they tell
us Nadia weighed 7.27 and Vanessa
weighed 8.34 we have to add those up and
really they just gave us this the length
of Nadia at Birth really as a
distraction just so that we just don't
mindlessly add any numbers we see so
this is really unnecessary information
just to distract us so we need to add
Nadia's birth weight plus Vanessa's so
it's seven point two seven so seven
point two seven plus eight point three
four and it's always important that we
line up the decimal and I'd like to do
the decimal first so it's eight point
three four and we'll just add these two
up so seven plus four and this is really
seven seven hundredths plus four
hundredths is eleven hundreds which is
the same thing as one hundredth and 1/10
1/10 plus two tenths plus three tenths
is six tenths we've got our decimal sign
right over there and then seven plus
eight is fifteen or you could even say
it's five ones and 1/10 and we're done
they weighed 15.6 one pounds in total